BRETT SLATKIN: And now, I'm
going to give it back to Kevin
to tell you more about it.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN GIBBS: Thanks, Brett.
That was great.
Woo, brisk night.
All right, well, now
I'm going to go back
into the five
components I talked
to you about a
little bit earlier,
the five big components
in the App Engine stack.
I'm going to dive down to
some more technical detail now
to get into some more
details of the product.
So the first of
our five components
is they're scalable
serving infrastructure.
We took this photo
earlier this morning,
where the team was backing
up before the launch.
Our scalable web
service infrastructure
is a big part of App Engine.
It's a distributed, low-overhead
system for running your code.
When you submit your code
to us, as you saw Brett do,
it's pushed to a number
of fault-tolerant servers
running within our data centers.
We handle all the work of
connecting the request down
from the user to a running
instance of your code
within the data center.
Now, when I say that the
system is fault-tolerant,
what I mean is that, across
our servers that we put
your code on, any
one of them could
fail at any moment in time.
And we will still connect your
request to one of our servers
and still be able to serve it.
It's part of how Google
does infrastructure.
And so another aspect,
which sort of follows
from that, about the way
that we serve your web apps
is that it's fluid.
We don't ask you to
reserve resources upfront.
You don't have to tell us
how many CPUs you want,
how many machines you need,
or anything like that.
Instead, we scale and move
your application in response
to demand, in response to load.
So that's the scalable web
serving infrastructure.
Again, a big part of
the goal of App Engine
is to make everything easy.
So that's one thing we just
take out of the equation
for you to make easier.
Now, our second big component
is our Python runtime.
As I mentioned, Python is
the first supported language
with App Engine.
However, I say the word runtime,
because our language support
in App Engine is
actually modular.
All the same infrastructure
that you're seeing here--
the set of APIs and the main
console-- all of the tools
that we're providing
for you are generic,
and they apply to
multiple languages.
So we can drop new
languages in later.
Now, the Python that
we use with App Engine
is the same Python that
you've grown to know and love.
There are a wealth of
third-party modules
and libraries that
you can use with them.
And in short, we want you to be
able to use any code that you'd
like with App Engine.
We don't want to restrict
you to any specific thing.
In fact, we don't
want to restrict you
to any specific type of
HTML, or CSF, or JavaScript,
or content type, or anything.
We want you to be able to
create any sort of web app
that you can think
of on App Engine.
So the next big component
that we've got is our SDK.
This is the environment that you
use to develop an app locally.
It's what you saw Brett
use just now in the demo.
We're releasing it today
for Linux, Mac, and Windows,
but it's written in pure Python.
So anywhere that you can get
a Python interpreter running,
you can likely get
the SDK running.
Now, the big benefit of the
SDK, why I really like it,
is how it cuts down the
code-compile-test cycle
for you.
We don't require you to deploy
your code to our servers
each time you want
to test it out.
Instead, you just
run it locally,
using the editors you're used
to, the tools you're used to.
And your changes show up
instantly as you're coding.
I think this brings a lot of
the fun back to programming.
So our fourth component
is the admin console.
Right here is a
screenshot of it.
This web-based admin
console is a big part
of the simpler alternative
we're providing for you.
In essence, we're
actually providing you
a simpler alternative
to the whole LAMP stack.
And the admin console is what
ties that together and provides
you all the tools
you're used to using.
It allows you to see the
status of your application.
It allows you to control who
can administer the application,
add other users as admin so that
they can upload new versions.
It allows you to control
which version of your app,
if you have multiple versions,
receives most of the traffic.
But it also provides a
number of additional tools
that you may be used to
using in different forms.
That includes tools for
looking at your request logs
and your application
logs, a Data Explorer,
which is our alternative for
a SQL administration tool.
It allows you to
look into your data
and check on the properties,
add new entities, and so forth.
It provides an
administration interface
for hooking up a domain
to your application.
You don't need to run just on
the default app spot domain
that you saw.
And it also provides
some stats, which
are collected in near
real time, which tell you
how much traffic
you're receiving,
what errors you're receiving,
and what URLs you're receiving
them on, and so forth.
So our fifth big component
is the datastore,
which is our persistence layer.
The datastore, it's a
schema-less object store that
supports millions of entities.
Under the covers, though,
what's interesting
about the datastore is it's not
implemented with a clustered
SQL database, which is how
you would usually provide
a large data storage layer.
Instead, it uses
Bigtable, which is
a piece of scalable
infrastructure
that we use here at Google.
Now, you can read some
papers online about Bigtable
if you want.
They're fascinating.
But the short of
it is that Bigtable
is a horizontally-distributed
scalable system that, again,
is fault-tolerant and spans
thousands of machines and tens
and thousands of disks.
It automatically
reacts to hotspots,
moving your data
around as load changes.
So the fact that we're using
Bigtable here, though, and not
SQL is a big difference.
It's a big departure from
what people are used to.
And we know that getting used
to this new way of doing things
and this new methodology
is going to take
a little getting used to.
There's some new tools
that you have to use.
There's some new ways you have
to program similar to the ones
that you saw Brett use.
Eventually, however, we
think that this will pay off.
We think that you may actually
come to like the system
a little bit better.
One big advantage of using
our system in the datastore
is that it's schema-less.
If you want to introduce
a new entity type,
or you want to add a new
properties to your entity,
like you saw Brett do,
there's nothing to it.
You don't have to go
and update your schema,
or deploy something
new, or break out.
It's just code.
So again, it gets back to making
the whole thing really easy
to do and allowing you
to just write your code.
So now, actually, I'm going
to dive in a little bit more
on a model class, which
is the way that we
expose the datastore primarily.
You saw Brett use
it a little bit ago.
And this right here is
defining a model class
for a story, which is
something like a typical news
story you might see, a
story on a news site.
This is just a
normal Python class.
There's nothing
special about it.
It's just an interface
that we're using
to get down to the datastore.
I define three properties here.
One is a title, which I
said is a type string.
That means it's indexed,
and you can query on it.
And we also have
a body property,
which I've said,
alternatively, is a type text.
By saying it's a
type text, I mean
that it is not
indexed, but instead,
can hold much more information.
Because it's not efficient to
index a really large string.
We've also added
an author property.
Now, this is a type user.
What this means is it
stores a rich object.
We use your account
object to be a login
user, which I can supply when
I'm creating this object.
So we don't just
support primitive types.
We also support more advanced
types with the datastore.
Now, I can go ahead and
start using this model
in my application.
Use it, write some code,
store some entities.
And then I can come back
and add more properties.
So here, I've gone and
added two more properties.
I added the date-time property
with the creation timestamp.
It's pretty straightforward.
But I've also added
a rating property.
Now, a rating property, you
might think, well, what's that?
That's a little unusual.
Well, this is one
of the Gdata types
that we support with Gdata,
another system from Google.
And it's actually
a semantic type.
With the datastore, we also
support richer semantic types,
which are very interesting.
Because then they allow
you to store an entity,
and get it back,
and work with it
in a generic way using an
XML namespace for each type
of the semantic type.
So that gives you a
taste of how you actually
go ahead and store data and
what you can do with our models.
Now, even though
we are a departure
from SQL with the datastore, we
provide a very powerful query
interface that is sufficient
for building real applications.
Some of the things that we
support with our querying
capabilities include
queries on a single property
or multiple properties,
sort orders--
again, on a single property
or multiple properties
as [INAUDIBLE] sending--
transactions, so that you
can write a group of entities
together with
consistency guarantees.
We also support things
like batch operations,
and user settable primary
keys, and a few other parts
of the system.
Now, to demonstrate
some of these to you,
I'm actually going
to show you a query.
I'm going to use GQL,
which is something
that you saw in the demo.
And GQL is a simplified,
SQL-like query language
that we provide.
It's similar to, in
spirit, things like jQuery
or FBQL, which, although
they're not SQL,
make it easy to interact
with other data sources.
[INAUDIBLE] showed that to you.
Here, with GQL, I've done a
pretty simple query, again,
off that same story class
that I just showed you.
Here, I said, I'd like
to select from stories,
where the title is App
Engine Launch, which
is happening right now.
And the author,
I've said, I want
that to be the current user.
That's in a keyword
argument that I passed
in when constructing the query.
That's a pretty simple query.
You can actually do considerably
more advanced queries.
So many other things
that you can show,
that you can do or ask
for in the same query--
object with the rating over
10 for rating property.
And I can also request that
the results be sorted by rating
and also to create
a timestamp, even
though it wasn't in the query.
So that gives you
an idea of the sort
of queries that we can support.
Now, I should also mention
that since we're not SQL,
there's another big feature
of SQL that we don't support,
and that's joins.
We don't provide joins for
you with the datastore.
And the reason that
we don't provide
joins is that joins
tend to only work well
in databases that are within
a single machine's memory.
When you go outside the
memory of a single machine,
and you run into
multiple machines,
it's hard to do
efficient algorithms
for implementing joins.
So that's why we
don't provide them.
But to actually
underscore something
that's a little bit
exciting about App Engine--
is that although we
don't provide it,
it's because the system
we're providing to you
allows your
applications to scale.
Because the datastore is built
on a horizontally-scalable,
fault-tolerance system, and your
data can span many hard disks
and machines and already does,
it means that if you create
your application carefully-- you
think it through a little bit
when you're writing it,
about how it might scale--
and you design your queries
a little bit of foresight,
your application
can easily scale
to millions of users and
millions of entities.
Those are the five
big components
in the App Engine stack.
Now, I did also want to
mention a couple other features
and APIs that we provide.
The first off is our
email-sending API.
That's another API
that we provide.
We allow you to create
and send emails.
But again, in the spirit of
App Engine, making things easy,
we don't require you to
set up an SNTP server
or do anything like that.
You just create a mail
object, and you can send it.
We also provide
the ability for you
to make outgoing HTTP requests
to the internet with our URL
fetch API.
This API is neat,
because it allows
you to integrate with existing
other services and web
services.
Another thing that we
provide is authentication
with Google Accounts.
Again, it's the
same sort of story.
You don't have to maintain
user objects and passwords
and do any of that.
We'll handle that for you.
When you create your app, you
already have a bed of users
that you can call from.
And finally, another big feature
is that we support frameworks.
Now, in the demo, you saw
us use a really simple
little framework that we provide
just to help you get started.
Well, we support much
larger frameworks,
like the whole Django framework.
Those are really
helpful when you
move from writing a small web
app to a much larger web that
has hundreds or
thousands of pages on it.
All right, well, those
are the big components
of the App Engine system.
I hope that now, after
giving you guys a quick talk,
you're able to see how we're
trying to provide a simpler
alternative for creating and
running web applications.